i didn't understand how to make a
billion dollars for a very very long
time and the first misunderstanding is
that you don't make a billion dollars to
become a billionaire you own stuff
that's worth the billion dollars to
become a billionaire let me walk you
through how i used to think this worked
so phase one high school alex was like
okay in order to be a billionaire i have
to make a billion dollars every year
which is ridiculous but that's what i
thought the second phase i was like oh
silly high school alex that's not how
you make a billion dollars all you have
to do is take home a billion two billion
dollars before taxes over your lifetime
and so then third season which is where
i'm at right now and you don't make it
you own it so let's say you own a
business that is making 10 million
dollars a year top line all right now
half of that is your profit if this
company is worth 10 times its earnings
and i'll explain why that like why a
company like this might be worth 10
times its earnings after taxes i take
home you know three good for me next
year because i'm in mosination and we
focus on the main asset that we have our
business and i go from five million
dollars a year in profit to six million
dollars here in profit doesn't sound
like a huge win right it's like hey
added a million bucks bottom line cool
this is great well if we have a 10x
multiple then something i own went from
being worth 50 million to being worth
60 million now i own 100 of that thing
and i just got something that
appreciated by 10 million dollars that i
didn't pay tax on wait a second what i
got out of the business only went from
three to three and a half million after
taxes right six at forty percent you get
three and a half to take home i only
made an extra 500 000 after taxes this
year now you made an extra 10 million
dollars after taxes because the thing
that you own appreciated by 10 million
and that's the thing that i didn't
understand for a very long time and so
now let's zoom out you want to be a
billionaire again it's not by me
side hustling my way to a billion like
zuckerberg didn't have airbnbs he was
flipping on the side while he's building
facebook what did you do to become a
billionaire he built facebook if you
have the opportunity to spend half of
your time obsessing about your passive
income rather than saying huh i wonder
if i could take my five million dollar
profit business focus all my attention
on it and make it into a six million
dollar profit business then all of a
sudden i just added 10 million to my net
worth and so this is how a billion
dollars actually is made you have
something that makes between 80 and 100
million dollars in ebitda or fancy word
for profit that you get a multiple on
and usually companies of that size tend
to trade 15 times earnings like if you
look at the s p all right so you'd
really only need somewhere in there for
like 70 million dollars in ebitda to be
a billionaire because you own the
company so it means that you'd have to
make a little bit more than 1.3 million
dollars 1.5 million dollars per week and
take home which i know that that sounds
crazy but like you have to think in
increments like imagine how much you
made five years ago as an entrepreneur
how crazy small does that feel to you
now because you've leveled up and so as
much as whatever number i just said to
you might sound like a lot five years
from now you might be in shooting
distance and so it's really just about
understanding like how do i reverse
engineer what has to happen and if you
want to be a billionaire it's like okay
well how do i make a million dollars 1.5
million dollars a week in profit well if
i'm running a 30 march in business i got
to make 6 million a week there's 52
weeks i gotta make 300 million top line
okay so then you can start actually
putting tangible goals to this i want to
become a billionaire you become a
billionaire by owning something worth a
billion dollars if you really want to be
smart about it you don't shoot for a
billion here's why you want to shoot for
10 billion or 50 billion and i know this
is gonna sound crazy but realistically i
would never imagine trying to pursue an
opportunity that was capped at 100
million a year you would have to think
about opportunities that one were not
limited by your time two could serve a
very big marketplace three had very high
gross margin and four you'd think
probably on a very very long time
horizon and then all of a sudden you're
thinking like a billionaire the goals we
have matter matter more because of how
we measure them and the increments in
which we use to build them more than
what the actual goal itself is and so
when someone tells me they have a goal
to make six figures what happens is
they're gonna think that six figures is
the cap and they're gonna break it down
in a tiny itty bitty units and they're
gonna basically say a hundred percent of
my effort equals one hundred thousand
dollars and they're gonna measure in
tiny units and then they're gonna do 100
effort and they're gonna be like ah i
was at 94 this year but if you're
thinking about making 10 million dollars
then you can you'll think in like okay
for me to make 10 million dollars i got
to sell let's say a 10 000 thing and i
got to sell a thousand of them okay that
means three ten thousand dollar things a
day and if i close one out of three
calls that means i have to take nine
calls a day okay well how much do i have
to spend to get a call for this thing
all of a sudden you start thinking in a
much bigger increment and if you're like
i don't know what i could sell for ten
thousand dollars well then you gotta
figure out something that makes someone
else a hundred thousand dollars and you
can sell something
that's worth 10. the reason you're not
making enough money is because you don't
know how to provide enough value the
reason that like a lot of the wealth in
the world sits with financiers is
because they know how to take someone
passively and they can say hey man just
give me a billion dollars and i'll just
make you 10 a year on it and they know
how to make 15 a year and they make that
extra five on a billion and they take
home 50 million a year and they're like
works for me if you can approach the
problem that way you'll start thinking
more along the lines of the people that
i think you're trying to emulate you
don't make it you own it you get paid
for what you do you get returns on what
you own that 50 million dollar business
that we were talking about before 10
million 5 million profit 10x why would
someone pay 10x or something you're like
i wouldn't pay 50 million dollars for
business that's making five let me tell
you why you would so if that business
went from five to six and then went
twenty percent again because that was a
twenty percent growth it went to seven
point two and then twenty percent again
would be eight point six and twenty
percent again would be what uh ten point
two you know and keep going if you added
all those things up you'd be at 40-ish
million in earnings over the next five
years remember we bought it for 50 but
wait
now we still own the thing and it's
making 12 and a half million in profit
wait if we just apply 10x and
realistically at this point it'd
probably be closer to 12x but let's just
still apply 10x for this now we have 125
million thing that we paid 50 for that
already paid us 40 back and this is
where it gets even juicier to buy that
50 million thing i didn't write a check
for 50. i wrote a check for 15 and i
took a loan for 35. huh and so then at
the end of this whole thing i put my 15
million down i pay back my loan for the
35 so i only have 10 million left over
that i got i got to pay back and now i
get 100 of that 125 million minus my
original 10 because i covered five of it
from from the cash flow oh i just made
120 million dollars that's why people do
it the smart money if you want to sell
to institutional investors they think
that way and so you have to think that
way about the assets that you own and
the assets that you're building that is
like ultimately how you can make huge
leaps in wealth